I'm against regulations,
so,
uh,
now,
yeah,
I think that as long as we find a way to
control,
uh,
the,
the flow of money that goes,
that would go to a,
to uh,
ill conceived initiatives and obviously
you have to think about terrorism at
this point.
Uh,
that's legitimate that we have
mechanisms to make sure that,
uh,
that we have a way to track illicit or
movements or suspicious movement of
money.
So this delicate balance here and this
is being done as we speak.
I mean probably more than we know or
care to know.
Uh,
but other than that I think to regulate
in the business sense of the word,
I think that game,
that would be a mistake because I
obviously a convinced a capitalist
not because it's the parent because it's
been a CEO,
not because it's,
it doesn't have any drawbacks,
but frankly we haven't found anything
better.
So to,
to,
to rise,
you know,
to raise the,
the level of the one.
So the road,
the road to progress up to now is
through a capitalistic system.
If we could find something better,
I'm wide open to it,
I'm open to it,
but we have not.
So,
and the essence of the capitalist system
is that you don't want to regulate it or
at least you certainly want to do the
minimum to make sure that there's order
is preserved and that again,
no illegal or illicit a things are being
done.
Huge change.
Um,
you know,
globalization has an,
some well known,
uh,
I wouldn't say he shares but well known
statements on this,
you know,
the world's flat.
And so,
which is true,
I mean,
to some extent,
it's true that the globalization has,
as we have moved for me,
national markets through a global
market.
So now people think they can play
anywhere everywhere in the world and
they are.
And this has created a situation where
large global company fairly acquired a,
a
or power,
uh,
that is very,
very significant.
Some of them have the citizenship to
deal with this,
the corporate values to deal with it.
Some of them may not yet,
but,
but they are getting there quickly
because they realize their
responsibility on,
in the world because of their presence.
Uh,
and uh,
to some extent that has a,
raised the awareness amongst the ceos of
large global companies that global
corporate citizenship is very important
and they have to deal with that and they
are,
and they are,
which is also one of the reasons they're
form is successful at attracting this
interest because that's when we talk
about that.
So,
uh,
so that's one thing.
The second thing is that
countries have sort of lost a fair
amount of power in this globalization
evolution,
uh,
and uh,
because of this goes across nations.
So this is,
this is a change that's interesting to,
to witness
and uh,
some countries react a smartly to this
and some not so smartly,
so,
uh,
but progressively inevitably,
this is going to go into the right
direction because business is getting
conscious of their responsibilities and
governance are starting to our
understanding how they can really deal
with this phenomenon more,
more effectively as an opportunity
rather than a threat.
Here's the big difference,
of course,
countries have gone to protectionist
measures.
Uh,
I've tried to,
uh,
contain a,
they are industry by artificial means
and that's not,
that's not the solution.
The solution is to not to look at this
as a threat,
but to look at it as an opportunity and
those who do
pa successful,
okay
at this point are saying that,
hey,
we can argue whether we will or will
not.
And to what extent we have recession,
putting her name on the economic
slowdown is always sort of artificial.
Here we started session is two quarters
of negative growth.
Okay.
So that's an arbitrary decision,
but so be it.
If that's the decision,
I don't know whether it will have that.
Maybe we do,
maybe we don't.
I think it's a material to a large
extent.
We will come out of this and grow again.
So it's only a temporary situation.
Now I've saved this.
Even if we have this,
uh,
the engines of growth in the rest of the
world are powerful enough that I don't
think this will trigger will recession
at all.
Uh,
because the,
uh,
there was Korean economies are just
unbelievable and uh,
if China grows at 10 percent a year or
nine percent a year,
if just started grant six percent a
year,
I mean,
this is still a lot of growth.
So,
uh,
so I don't see,
I don't see that as a problem at all.
I think
the purchasing power of Americans is
decreasing and will continue to
decrease.
I think this is inevitable as a result
of this global trend.
Uh,
so,
so some of the other countries are
raising to that level,
coming to that level.
I think,
as I said earlier,
the bigger problem is the income
disparity between Africa and the rest of
the world.
I think this is,
this,
this property did a more serious issue
on that particular question that in my
view,
we have.
Yeah.